for this enemy on the other hand what is
the essence is not the in itself the
implicit universal but individuality its
power therefore is the negative
principle for which nothing is
established or absolutely sacred but
which can risk and endure the loss of
anything and everything in doing so it
is just in certain of victory through
its own resources as through the
contradiction in which its opponent gets
entangled what virtue holds to be an
intrinsic being the way of the world
regards is merely in a different object
it is free from every principle that
virtue holds to be established and by
which it is bound such a principle the
way of the world has in its power since
it regards it as something it can either
set aside or let be as it can also the
virtuous knight who is fast bound by it
the latter cannot disentangle himself
from it as it were a cloak thrown around
him which he could from which he could
free himself by leaving it behind for it
to him it is something essential which
he must not give up
moving now into paragraph 387 what we
see Hegel depicting is just how
disadvantaged virtue turns out to be by
its own reliance on what makes it virtue
and correspondingly how advantaged in
relation to it the way of the world
turns out to be as well so let's let's
follow this out he says for this enemy
on the other hand what's the enemy the
way of the world what is the essence is
not the in itself the implicit universal
but individuality that's that's what
it's doing as essential its power
therefore he says is the negative
principle the principle for which
nothing is established or absolutely
sacred but which can risk and endure the
loss of anything and everything this is
a instance of what Hegel in the preface
then that very famous passage talks
about as the you know the labor of the
negative right and now we're getting to
see it play itself out he's actually
going to use the term out of a bong in
this this passage as something that's
that's allowable for the way of the
world if it wants to do that or it can
you know do something else instead it
can can you know affirm something rather
than overcome it
so it says in doing so it is just a
certain of victory through its own
resources as through the contradiction
in which its opponent gets entangled now
think back to last paragraph right what
was the reserve the ace and the whole
the you know forces held back that
virtue was going to deploy in an end
maneuver around and take you know the
way of the world from behind and defeat
it well part of that consisted in its
own understanding of the way of the
world
the
fact that you know virtue has a unity of
purpose the way of the world doesn't
have anything remotely like that it's
just this jarring set of individuality
'he's all you know coordinated with each
other if there's any sort of regularity
it's only a local regularity right or
something at the lowest level like
self-interest rules the day alright so
now it's the way of the world that
actually knows something about virtue
and what it knows is virtue is bound by
its own rules this is something that we
see played out quite a quite a lot in
movies don't we we see this with action
hero movies you know the tragic moment
do you kill the bad guy the bad guy
knows you can't really kill him because
if you did then you would be just as bad
as him right and so he pushes your your
wife and children off the cliff or you
know kills your buddy or blows up the
car whatever he's going to do destroys
you know the financial system perhaps if
we're talking about Fight Club right so
there's an advantage that that the way
of the world has which is that it it's
not bound like virtue is virtue is bound
by these principles its entangled as we
saw in contradictions veter sport right
it can't get itself out of those we saw
that it couldn't even fight the opponent
that it claims to be fighting against
adequately so he goes on and he says
what virtue holds to be an intrinsic
being the way of the world regards is
merely an indifferent object now this is
a bit of a complex translation of
something that in the German is actually
much simpler for virtue what on Zeek
issed what what has being in itself or
is in itself that's why Miller is
translating here is intrinsic being it
has substance substantiality has value
in it of itself for the way of the world
this
is merely in a different object or
another way simpler way in the German
nerve for Nina it's just for the way of
the world whatever the way of the world
wants to do with that is fine and so how
does that play itself out
he says it is free from every principle
that virtue holds to be established
virtue is bound by those principles that
it observes such a principle has the way
of the world such a principle the way of
the world he has in its power since it
regards it as something it can either
set aside Alf haben or let be as it can
also the virtuous night who is fast
bound by it so notice this if the way of
the world at this point is conscious of
its own superiority in the conflict that
virtue initiate it's not the way of the
world who initiated virtue initiated
this conflict and the way of the world
is like hey buddy I see that you
actually have to fight this way well I
don't fight that way let me poke you in
the eyes oh yeah that's not fair
fighting oh I'm sorry
let me fix that for you now I'll pull
your hair and you know knee you in the
groin and go on and go ahead and go on
right it's very much like seeing fights
where somebody has been training for
fighting and they think that everybody
has to follow those rules and what do
they do and they get into a real fight
they get beat up very quickly you know
we could come up with other examples as
well you could think of people who think
that there's you know hard and fast
rules that aren't really a matter of
individuals or well you know what what
is being accepted by the way of the
world at this point in time when it
comes to romance dating you know erotic
connections all those sorts of things
people want to say oh these are hard and
fast rules I obey them you all should
obey them and everybody else is like hey
buddy I can either obey them or not obey
them I don't have the sort of emotional
attachment that you do to following the
rulz we see this happen in gaming
communities as well games by their very
nature tend to be bound with rules but
also have openings where people can
exploit the rules and use them to their
own advantage and that that really
drives certain gamers nuts when they see
people doing that sort of thing happens
in music as well right a lot of musical
innovation comes about by dispensing
with the rules the principles and you
know the purists are like you can't do
that alright so he goes on and he says
the virtuous knight is fast bound by
these principles he cannot disentangle
himself from it as if it were a cloak
thrown round him from which he could
free himself by leaving it behind why
because it's part of who he is
it's part of what virtuous for to him
here's how Hegel ends it it is something
essential which he must not give up why
not if he does give it up if he adopts
the greater freedom of movement virtue
becomes indistinguishable then from the
way of the world
finally as regards the ambush from which
the intrinsically good is to attack the
way of the world cunningly from the rear
this is essentially a vain hope the way
in the world is the alert self-assured
consciousness that cannot be got out
from behind but faces in every direction
for its nature is that everything is
merely an object for it that everything
stands in front of it but when the
intrinsically good is an indifferent
object for the enemy that it is involved
in the conflict we have seen but insofar
as it is not such an object but
possesses intrinsic being it is the
passive instrument of gifts and
capacities a material lacking reality if
represented is a real being it would be
a dormant consciousness one remaining in
the background no one knows where
the conflict develops further in
paragraph 388 and what we see happening
now is this conflict is going on between
virtue in the way of the world and we
saw that that virtue thought that it had
some sort of advantage over the way of
the world that had this reserve we
talked about it as the faith or the
belief the globo that it has in the
unity of its own purpose and in the
essential nature of the way of the world
this contrast between them we saw that
that doesn't really hold up and in the
previous paragraph but virtue is still
relying on this it can't win here so it
sneaks around and it's going to hit the
way of the world from behind but what
does it find out and finds out that the
way of the world is actually not so easy
to take
it's like Hegel says looking in all
directions so he says as regards this
ambush from which the intrinsically good
that is you know the goodness the the
Isaac you know you know that that the
virtue is relying on is to attack the
way the world cunningly from the rear
this is a vain hope there isn't any rear
to its heck the the way of the world
from it doesn't have a rear because it's
looking in every direction all at the
same time says the way of the world is
the alert self assured consciousness
that cannot be got at from behind why
because it faces in every direction it
is like the Argos of legend that has
eyes looking in every single vector that
it might be gotten at the you know
there's supposed to be this great
watchdog all right so he goes on and he
says it's nature is that everything is
merely an object for it that everything
stands in front of it this is a really
interesting way of speaking here that
Hegel is in
gauged in so the way of the world looks
at everything as not having intrinsic
being not having an in itself that it
has to respect that it has to deal with
as such but rather the way of the world
can do what it likes with it it can
respect it if it wants to but it doesn't
have to if you know interest demands
that the great works of art be turned
into paper mache for my party well then
that's up to me if I buy them that's
sort of the way of the world
right and virtue doesn't get this virtue
still wants things to like follow
certain rules and it thinks that just by
making this end run it will be able to
say aha I've got you now but it doesn't
and you know we see this again if we
want to use I brought up the example of
movies you know action movies where you
have a hero and a villain and the
villain represents the way of the world
the villain is able to you know say I'm
gonna do whatever I need to do and the
hero is bound by certain rules so the
hero has you know the villains say
spouse or favorite henchman or whatever
and someone who matters ostensibly to
the villain and the hero says if you
don't put down your weapon I'm going to
kill him or her right and what does the
villain inevitably do the villain says
go ahead what why not you go ahead and
do that you'll be just as bad as me and
you don't know how to handle that I've
got a whole career of working as a
villain I know how to handle that or I
know you won't do it so don't even
bother threatening to do it because I
know you you don't have the guts you
know and these sorts of things and so
what ends up happening is you know
what's supposed to turn into an ambush
turn
to a counter ambush right because the
way of the world is already there
looking so he goes on and he says when
the intrinsically good the on Zeke is an
indifferent object for for you know
something for the enemy then it is
involved in the conflict we have seen
then he goes on he says insofar as it's
not such an object but in it possesses
intrinsic being it's the passive
instrument of gifts and capacities it's
something that can be thrown into the
balance a material lacking reality it's
it's just there to be used in whatever
way we choose to the gifts and
capacities of the individual then he
goes on he says if represented as a real
being as a design it would be a dormant
sleeping schlafen to consciousness one
remaining in the background no one knows
where so what we see here is what looks
like a triple impasse for virtue and a
victory assured for the way of the world
virtue therefore is conquered by the way
of the world because its purpose is in
fact the abstract unreal essence and
because its action as regards reality
rests on distinctions which are purely
nominal it wanted to consist in bringing
the good into actual existence by the
sacrifice of individuality but the sight
of reality is itself nothing else but
the sight of individuality the good was
supposed to be that which has an
implicit being and to be opposed to what
is but the in itself taken in its real
and true sense is rather being itself
the in itself is in the first instance
the abstraction of essence in contrast
to reality but an abstraction is
precisely what is not true but exists
for consciousness which means however
that it is itself what is called real
for the real is that which is
essentially for an other or is being but
the consciousness of virtue rests on
this distinction between the in itself
and being a distinction which has no
truth the way of the world was supposed
to be the perversion of the good because
it had individuality for its principle
only individuality is the principle of
the real world for it is precisely
individuality that is consciousness
whereby what exists in itself exists
equally for another it does pervert the
unchangeable but it perverts it in fact
from the nothing of abstraction into the
being of reality
Hegel begins paragraph 389 by saying
that virtue has been conquered by the
way of the world so we've really come
quite a ways I mean this section is the
bount virtue and it started out with
virtue being very dynamic something that
perhaps could could defeat the way of
the world that could be changing the
world to conform to virtue at least a
part of the world right but instead
virtue at least in the sense that Hegel
is using it here again remember we're
not talking about virtue in the ancient
sense but virtue in a much more modern
sense virtue is beat it's unable to
grapple with the way of the world why
like it says its purpose is in fact the
abstract unreal essence what we're going
to see in this paragraph over and over
again is Hegel drooling home to us the
fact that the distinction that virtue
wants to rely upon between the in itself
and being turns out not to be a viable
distinction at all everything ends up
collapsing everything ends up being
sucked into the way of the world so he
says its purpose is in fact the abstract
unreal essence it's action as regards
reality rests on distinctions which are
purely nominal now what does that mean a
nominal distinction is a distinction
that you can make that isn't really
going to hold up you're just calling
something two different names so for
example chalk writing instrument right
crazy you know we can use foreign words
if we want whatever track happens to be
in Latin I don't really know but chuck
is in Latin they're all describing the
same thing those are nominal
distinctions is this a tie or is it a
cravat people do this in the fashion
industry all the time right they make
all sorts of distinctions why because
they they're not quite so nominal when
they eject the
price up right or or say no no we don't
wear that sort of thing this season last
season you could have worn a cravat like
that this season now you must wear a tie
oh okay well we'll call it a tie now
that the nominal distinction so a lot of
the distinctions that virtue has been
relying upon turn out to be of that sort
so he says it wanted to consist in
bringing the good into actual existence
by the sacrifice of individuality but
what is it fine
the sight of reality is itself nothing
else but the side of individuality it's
attempting to realize the good through
its action directed at its purpose it's
vac and you know creating a good but it
says the good is supposed to be that
which has an implicit being that which
is on Zeke and to be opposed to what is
but the in itself taken in it's it's
real and true sense is rather being
itself so this this contrast between the
in itself and being is itself negated
again this is what we call determinate
negation right we have a negation first
of in itself and being and then instead
of just saying oh well what would be the
negation of not equal we just make an
equal sign here
no we negate the whole thing we say this
doesn't hold up we're not actually
working with two separate terms even the
equal sign maintains a kind of you know
distinction between them that is not
particularly useful here they're
speaking a little bit metaphorically at
this point right now he goes on and he
says the in itself is in the first
instance the abstraction of essence in
contrast to reality but an abstraction
is precisely what is not true but exists
only for consciousness which means
however that is it is itself what is
called real so an abstraction is not
something true something that it is
something that only exists for
consciousness you know when people
accuse Hegel of only dealing with
abstract
this is a great passage to point them
towards Hegel thinks that sooner or
later we have to grapple with reality
our abstractions better connect up with
reality at some point they do in fact
permeate it they penetrate it but they
do so because consciousness is driving
them like nails or hooks into reality so
where do we go from here he says the
real is essentially what is for another
or as being but the consciousness of
virtue rests on this distinction that we
have now nullified between the in itself
and being a distinction which has no
truth why does it have no truth it is an
abstraction now here's where he says
something really interesting the way of
the world was supposed to be the
perversion of the good because it had
individuality for its principle so what
we're talking about perverting here you
know pervy air today in Latin fare Canon
to turn you know so the way of the world
was supposed to be a turning aside of
the good right a perversion of the way
things ought to be of what what is
valuable now what does Hegel do here he
says only individuality is the principle
of the real world individuality is
what's real abstractions are not real he
says it is precisely individuality that
is consciousness that's really important
to keep in mind it's not just this
gigantic hive mind that you know we call
spirit or something like that
the way that people sometimes depict
Hegel is talking about individuality
--zz do in fact matter they are
consciousnesses and they're not going to
be just you know totally absorbed or
fused into the absolute or something
like that ultimately we're trying to
drive to the point where individuality
is can't exist in there
relatedness and their distinction from
each other so he goes on and he talks
about this perversion again says it does
eat it does pervert the unchangeable but
it perverts it notice what he's saying
it turns it out if we want to use a
common term like when you turn somebody
out you're in essence perverting them
right you get them hooked on something
and now you get them turning tricks for
you okay so it turns it out in fact from
the nothing of abstraction into as he's
going to talk about it the being of
reality that's signed the reality 10th
through its action it spots it brings
about reality tats so the good if it's
going to really be good that virtue is
realizing it has to be in reality and it
has to be good that involves
individuality so this this notion of
like you don't have this ideally you
know totally selfless only bound by
principal-agent Hegel's rejecting that
here Hegel saying that's empty and that
that is empty time you know for example
will tell you yes of course it's empty
that's precisely what's so great about
it
Hegel says no no no no that's not so
great
as a matter of fact where things
actually do get done they get done by
real individual agents realizing real
goods and so what does that mean that
means that the way of the world has
indeed triumphed over virtue at this
point
you